wardrobe and audio thank you
has this been the craziest outfit you
wore before
oh sorry ladies picture yeah one of the
craziest i think so far baby
[Music]
or
yeah no wait hold on
right through there yep there you go
what
there we go
that [ __ ] coming through here
candy
hey guys i'm mike the spelling bee
beautiful bee baby
don't be jealous cause i'm
beautiful okay why are you wearing that
because i'm ready to breathe
i'm a bee that's ready to breed with the
queen
[Music]
bill
he flow like a butterfly and he's still
like a spelling bee please welcome mike
tyson
[Music]
do i
are you ready yeah i'm ready all right
sequential oh i got it
what
did you say it yeah oh see i went
can you use it in a sentence please no
using a fan yeah
stock squats is just too big
oh
i'm going to just
i'm going to say you
i'm gonna say s e
q
u e n
t i
l
no
it's sesquicentennial
but you didn't spell it correctly there
what did i do
we got it wrong that's what you do i
spelled sequential oh i'm sorry well
maybe you should learn to spell
if anyone makes fun of you it's going to
be that guy on the end all right all
right
[Music]